- [Narrator] This
program is a presentation
of UCTV for educational and
non-commercial use only.
(bright instrumental music)
- So let's see if I'm doing my math right,
today is day 2585 of our
90 day mission to Mars.
(audience clapping)
The mission is still
going on and in the next
hour or so I'm gonna try to share with you
some of the adventure story that has been
the Mars Exploration Rover project.
This of course is Mars,
the object of our affections,
it's a truly terrible place.
If you went there you
would absolutely hate it.
The average temperature is about
60 degrees below zero, Celsius.
It goes down to minus 100 at night.
If you took all the water
vapor on the Martian surface
and you condensed it out,
took all the water vapor
in the Martian atmosphere
and condensed it out
on the planet's surface
you'd make a layer of frost barely
one hundredth of a millimeter thick.
So it's a cold and dry
and desolate world today.
But in the past it was different.
This is a picture that
was taken from orbit,
and it shows a little sinuous valley
across the Martian surface and this valley
was carved by flowing water.
In fact you can look up here and you can
actually see in the upper right the little
channel through which
the water that carved
that valley flowed.
But you can't do this on Mars today.
On Mars today it's too cold,
and it's too dry to allow
something like this to happen.
So what this is telling
us is that in the past
it was different.
It was warmer, it was wetter,
it may have been more like Earth.
Now any geologist will tell you that
any place that you have
erosion somewhere else
there has to be deposition.
And there are places
that you can go on Mars
where you'll find these wonderful
sequences of layered sedimentary rocks.
The great thing about
layered sedimentary rocks
is that they preserve in their details,
in their chemistry, in their texture,
information about what
the conditions were like
when the rocks were laid down.
So if can go to these rocks,
you can find them and then you can
investigate them with
the right set of tools
you can read the story that
the rocks have to tell,
about what conditions were
like on Mars long ago.
Was it warm, was it wet,
were there conditions there
that would have been suitable for life.
So to do this we built
two robot geologists.
This picture was taken at Cape Canaveral
over seven years ago,
this is the Rover Spirit,
in the foreground, all tricked
out and ready to go to Mars,
you can see Opportunity
in the background there
doesn't have her wheels on yet,
on the handsome guy in
the white suit here.
And these rovers
effectively are surrogates.
We explore Mars through their sensors
we see Mars through their eyes.
The rover itself carries
a scientific payload
and the scientific payload
comes in two main parts.
One part is supported
by that big fat white
stovepipe looking thing, that mast there,
and that sports two instruments,
one is a set of very high resolution
color stereo cameras
at the top of the mast,
and then down at the base of the mast
there's an infrared spectrometer.
And what that does is
it looks up the inside
of the mast, it's hollow on the inside,
and then there's a pair
of mirrors at the top
that can be used to scan the countryside,
this thing's basically a periscope.
And so the infrared spectrometer
gets the same view of
Mars that the cameras get.
Once we've identified interesting rocks
using the camera, using the spectrometer,
we then can drive over to them,
and on the front end of
the vehicle there's an arm.
The arm has a shoulder,
an elbow, and a wrist,
it has exactly the same
dimensions as my arm,
which is purely a
coincidence. (audience laughs)
And at the end of the arm there's a hand
and the hand has four fingers on it,
there's a microscope for telling us
what the rocks look like close up,
two more spectrometers for telling us
what the rocks are made of in detail,
and this device here that we call the RAT,
R-A-T the rock abrasion tool.
And that's a diamond tip grinding tool
that can grind away the
outer surface of a rock,
kind of opening a window
into it's interior
for the other instruments to look through.
Now the spacecraft that gets
this contraption to Mars
is built sort of like one
of those Russian doll sets,
you know where there's
a doll inside a doll
inside a doll, it's like that.
The rover, shown here, folds up in this
horrifyingly intricate fashion,
to produce a compact little package
that will then fit inside the lander.
This is the lander here.
Now lander has these three things
on the sides that we call petals.
Because they're like
the petals of a flower
and what they do is they fold up
around the rover,
enclosing it, encasing it,
protecting it, and producing this kind of
tetrahedral pyramid.
That's what the lander looks like when
it's all folded up.
That is then encased in
turn in another shell
that has two parts, the first part here
is called the heat
shield and what this does
is protect the vehicle during it's fiery
descent through the Martian atmosphere.
That cone shaped thing
that goes on the back,
we call the back shell and that completes
that outer shell.
And then this kind of blue frisbee
looking deal on the back end,
we call that the cruise stage.
And what the cruise stage provides is
propulsion, electrical power,
the stuff you need to get you to Mars.
This is what the spacecraft looks like
when it's all put together,
this is the Spirit
spacecraft hanging inside
a giant thermal vacuum chamber at
the Jet Propulsion Laboratory where we did
the assembly and testing of the vehicles.
We launched them in the summer of 2003,
two Delta II rockets from
Cape Canaveral in Florida,
one in the daytime, and one at night.
The launches were beautiful
exhilarating things to see.
It took us seven months to get to Mars.
Now once you get to Mars,
you hit the top of the Martian
atmosphere going Mach 27.
27 times the speed of sound.
That heat shield bleeds off kinetic energy
slows the vehicle down,
and then once you get down
to a nice leisurely Mach 2,
you deploy a supersonic parachute.
We learned the hard way
that supersonic parachutes
are very difficult things
to design and build.
The lander descends on a long cord,
and this is what the vehicle
looks like as it's still
screaming down towards the Martian surface
at three or four hundred miles an hour.
You do not drift down lazily
on a parachute on Mars.
The atmosphere is too thin.
We had a terrible time
with our parachutes.
These are some stills from a video
of the first test that we did of
the parachute design that we thought
would land us successfully on Mars.
Remember we did these tests at a
National Guard gunnery range
outside of Boise Idaho.
It's the kind of place where you can drop
big heavy things from the sky
and they won't kill anybody.
And we dropped our test article from
a helicopter at 4000 feet,
the parachute deployed,
it blossomed to make this beautiful
perfect orange and white bowl,
and then it just exploded.
It just ripped to ribbons.
And parachute after parachute failed.
What had happened was that as
the design of our vehicle matured,
our understanding of how
heavy it would be got bigger.
And by the time we did these tests
the vehicle was too
heavy for the parachute
to successfully land it.
So we had to go on a crash
program of parachute redesign,
we actually came up with three different
parachutes that we designed in parallel,
praying that one of them would work.
One of them did, we did our final
testing of the parachutes in a big NASA
wind tunnel just across the bay
at NASA Ames Research Center.
This is the design,
this is the design of the actual parachute
that landed successfully on Mars.
This test, our first successful test,
of a parachute, took place only eight
months before we had to be on top of
the rocket in Florida.
So it was a really scary schedule.
We'd land using air bags.
The air bags inflate
explosively around the vehicle.
They're sort of like
the airbags in your car
except a lot more expensive.
And then what happens is we fire
the solid rocket motors oh maybe
20, 30 meters above the surface,
we cut the airbags free,
and they fall to the
surface and they bounce.
And they bounce and they
bounce and they bounce
and they roll and they roll and they roll
and they can bounce and
roll as much as a kilometer
before the vehicle finally comes to rest.
And this is just a, an airbag engineer,
JPL being consumed by his
work. (audience laughs)
We had an awful time with the airbags too.
This is some stills again from a video
of our first airbag testing this was done
at a NASA, the world's
largest vacuum chamber
it's a NASA facility in Sandusky Ohio.
And you can sort of tell
from the looks on their faces
it's not going real well,
I mean the way this test works
you decompress this chamber and then
basically use giant bungee cords to whack
the airbags down onto a panel that's
studded with sharp pointy rocks
and the bags just ripped, they shredded.
And that right there that's a gaping hole,
in one of the bags.
Again what had happened is the design of
the vehicle had become so heavy that
the airbags couldn't handle it.
And so we had to strengthen the bags
adding layer upon layer upon layer to them
making them heavier making
the other problems even worse.
We eventually got the airbags to work too.
The picture on the left is from
one of our first successful airbag tests
and of course the ultimate test,
these are airbag bounce marks
on the surface of Mars.
Now once this thing lands,
we retract the airbags, the petals open up
and it flips the vehicle right side up.
And then inside, all folded up still
is the rover, looking
nothing like a rover yet.
So this thing now has to
do origami in reverse,
unfolding itself through multiple stages
to turn itself into a rover.
Now there were a lot of
parts of this mission
that made me nervous but
this part right here,
with all the gears and motors
and springs and hinges and latches,
was terrifying.
What you're seeing right here,
those are the solar arrays.
Those carry the life
giving solar cells that
must be exposed to the
sun the first day on Mars
and if they aren't,
the vehicle doesn't survive
the first night on Mars.
The camera mast comes up,
the antenna comes out,
and now by the time we
get to this configuration,
the vehicle is safe.
The sun is shining on the
solar arrays so we have power,
the mast is up so we can take pictures,
the antenna's out so we can transmit
those pictures back to Earth.
But we can't go anywhere yet,
because the whole suspension system
is still folded up underneath the vehicle.
There's another step, and
it's even worse, watch this.
There's a jack underneath the vehicle
like the jack in your
car that lifts it up,
and now watch what the
front wheels do, watch this.
Yeah, I mean. (audience laughs)
It's been seven years and I still
get the heebie-jeebies watching that.
You know if those latches don't latch,
you're done, your mission is over.
Now when we came up with this whole
cockamamie scheme for landing on Mars
with the heat shield and the parachute
and the airbags and the bouncing
and the unfolding and everything,
we thought that once we
got to this configuration,
with the vehicle standing
up on the lander deck
we were pretty much home free.
We just cut the cable that connects
the rover to the lander,
we go monster trucking down
onto the Martian surface,
and everything's good.
And we did some tests. (audience laughs)
Yeah this was a bad day.
It turns out that when
you drive one of these
vehicles off a lander it can flip
upside down under certain conditions.
So we had to fix that.
The solution that we came
up with you actually saw
when those petals first opened.
Between the petals, made of
fabric, we built some ramps.
And what happens is when
the petals fold into place,
the ramps, which are just fabric,
they're made of the same fabric
as the airbags really tough stuff,
those snap into position.
And then the rover can
drive down the fabric ramps.
Now once you get on the Martian surface
you gotta deal with the fact
that it's not exactly paved.
There are rocks and bumps
and drifts and dunes
and things that the rover
has to be able to negotiate.
And so our mechanical
engineers had to come up
with a scheme whereby the wheels of this
complex six-wheeled vehicle could go over
topography and could conform to whatever
topography they encountered without
the rover bumping around
too much, or tipping over.
It's an elegant system, this
sort of shows it in action.
Watch this, watch the wheels,
watch the suspension system.
As we go over this topography, watch this.
Isn't that cool?
I mean if we find a corrugated metal roof
on Mars we're all set. (audience laughs)
But watch we'll do a little spin here,
it's a very very elegant system.
Really neat mechanical engineering.
Okay now driving.
How do you drive this thing.
What I wish I had of course,
is a joystick, right.
What I wanna be able to
do is sit in my office
and steer it around rocks
and other obstacles,
but you can't do that.
Now on the night we landed,
when Earth and Mars were
pretty close together
it still took ten minutes
for that radio signal
traveling at the speed of
light to go from Earth to Mars.
Something happens on Mars,
ten minutes for the result to come back,
twenty minute round trip,
I'm gonna run into a rock.
Okay so what we've had to do instead,
is endow the vehicles with vision
and intelligence and the
ability to make their
own decisions about what
is safe and what is not.
And what we've done is we've
built into the vehicles
a pair of these wide
angle, googly-eyed cameras,
that take this 120 degree fish eye view
off the front end or the
back end of the vehicle
and they build up a
little three dimensional
model in their computer brain of what the
topography looks like.
And they can compute is that obstacle
small enough that I can drive over it.
Or is it big enough that
I have to go around it.
And we can program different levels
of courage, or cowardice,
into the vehicles
depending on how difficult and dangerous
we think the terrain is.
Here's a drive that was done by
Spirit early in the mission.
The first part here we
commanded explicitly
but from here on the rover's gonna be
making it's own decisions
and this is exactly what it did.
So it drove along and then right here,
there was a scary pile of rocks.
So it thinks about it for a minute
thinks about it, says okay I can do this,
I'll do it backwards, makes
that beep beep beep sound
you know as it's backing up.
Another pile of rocks here,
thinking about it, thinking about it,
says okay I'll go this way,
and I think they told
me to stop right here.
All done.
They're pretty smart little vehicles.
Okay the RAT.
The Rock Abrasion Tool.
This is one of the most important parts
of the science payload.
When a rock sits on the
surface of a planet,
it get exposed to the elements.
Sunlight, dust, wind, humidity,
these are things that produce a process
that geologists call weathering.
It modifies the surface of a rock.
What it does is it destroys the evidence
of what that rock was originally like.
So if you wanna know what
the rock is really like
you need to be able to get through that
weathered material and down
into the fresh rock underneath
and our tool for doing this is the RAT.
It has these diamond tipped grind heads
that spin at 3000 rpm.
And they can over a period of time
grind into the hardest rocks that
we've encountered on Mars.
So the RAT is effectively,
it's a power tool.
It's the world's first
interplanetary power tool
and as with all power tools
we have to be very careful
when we use the rat, so that
we don't (audience laughs)
do anything like that, I'm sorry.
I thought the wheel coming off was
a nice touch anyway. (audience laughs)
Alright, let's go to Mars.
I'm gonna start with Spirit.
The landing site that we chose for Spirit
is this crater, big
blue crater right there
it's called Gusev crater,
it's about 160 kilometers in diameter
it lies at 16 degrees
south latitude on Mars.
The reason we chose it,
what sets this crater apart,
is this.
There's a great big dried up riverbed
flowing into that crater.
Now there's no water in that riverbed now
and there hasn't been
for billions of years.
But this is a big hole in the ground
with a dry river flowing into it
there has to have been a lake
in Gusev crater at some point in the past.
So we went to Gusev hoping
and expecting to find
layered sedimentary rocks that had been
laid down billions of years
ago in a Martian lake.
We landed, and we saw this, nice and flat,
easy for driving.
I managed to convince
myself for about three days
that this is what a Martian dry
lake bed ought to look like.
But then we started looking at the rocks.
The first rock that we looked
at was this one right here.
We named it Adirondack
it's about that big.
And we hit this thing with
everything that we had.
We drilled into it with the RAT,
we looked at it with our spectrometers,
with our microscope,
we did everything we could to this rock,
and what we found,
and you can sort of guess
just by looking at it,
is this is not a sedimentary rock at all.
There are no layers in that.
It's a piece of lava this is basalt
this is a volcanic rock.
And every other rock for kilometers
in every direction is
the exact same stuff.
We landed on a bunch of lava.
Mars faked us out here.
I still believe those layered sediments
must be down there somewhere
but what happened was after
the sediments were deposited,
they were covered with lava.
And we didn't know that until we landed
and reached out and touched the rocks.
So this was a bitter disappointment.
Now our rovers were designed
to last for 90 Martian days,
and to drive 600 meters
over their lifetimes.
When we landed and we looked around,
off to the southeast
at a distance of about
two and a half kilometers,
we saw this beautiful range of hills.
We name them the Columbia Hills
after the Columbia space shuttle.
At two and a half kilometers away
they seemed impossibly distant.
But given the fact that
we realized quickly
that there as nothing
but lava in this scene.
We realized that we had to go to
the Columbia Hills or else we were
gonna see nothing but
lava the whole mission.
So off we went.
We reached the base of the Columbia Hills
on day 156 of our 90 day mission,
and everything changed.
The minute we entered the
hills everything was different.
This is the view from the base of
one of the highest hills in the range
this one is named Husband Hill
it's named after Rick Husband who was
the commander of the
Columbia when it went down.
And this is the hill
that we chose to climb.
We worked our way over a period of
hundreds of Martian days,
up the slopes of Husband Hill,
finding some very different
rocks along the way.
This is a picture, set of pictures taken
with our microscopic imager,
this image here is just
three centimeters across.
So now we're seeing layering.
Now we're seeing sub-centimeter
scale layering in the rocks.
When we look at these rocks
with our spectrometers
we start to see other minerals
we see minerals like goethite,
which is an iron oxy hydroxide.
Hydroxide, that means that you need water
to make goethite.
So now we're starting to see layered rocks
we're starting to see rocks that show
compelling evidence of
water being implicated
in their formation.
Over a period of hundreds of Martian days
we did the first ever
mountaineering on Mars,
working our way laboriously
up to the summit
of a Martian mountain as tall as
the Statue of Liberty.
Like any good mountaineer,
we took a picture when we got to the top.
This is part of the spectacular view
from the summit of Husband Hill
looking off to the south.
And as we speak, the Spirit
rover is right there,
having spent nearly 2600
days on the surface of Mars.
Spirit has had a tough time.
Martian mountaineering is
pretty tough on a robot.
And after about 800 days
of driving this vehicle,
the right front wheel failed.
So the right front wheel
would no longer turn.
And what that meant was,
that when we drove the vehicle
we had to drive it backwards,
dragging that dead wheel through the soil.
It made it very hard to drive.
What we discovered though
was that this cloud
had a wonderful silver lining in that
dragging that wheel digs this marvelous
hundreds of meters long trench
through the Martian soil.
And what we found to our surprise was that
every so often something fascinating
will pop up in the floor of that trench.
There was one day when we were driving
the rover very close to where I showed
you in that most recent image,
we're driving the rover
through a little valley,
and at the end of the drive,
the front wheel, the right front wheel
had dredged up some soil that was
as bright as white snow.
This caught our attention.
We went over with our spectrometers,
we made a measurement of the
composition of this stuff.
This one is, this stuff
is 91% pure silica, SiO2.
This is not quartz, not beach sand,
this is amorphous silica.
This is opal, sort of like the gemstone.
This is the kind of stuff
that typically forms in
hot springs, and volcanic
steam vents on Earth.
So what this silica deposit in this little
valley on Mars is pointing to,
is an environment billions of years ago
that would have been
one, suitable for life.
You can go to volcanic steam vents
you can go to hydrothermic
systems on Earth
and they're teeming with microbial life.
Now I do not know if life was ever here,
but these silica deposits
in this valley represent
a former habitable environment on Mars.
Of course we named the
place Silica Valley.
Spirit has had a tough
life in another way too.
This is a picture that the vehicle,
this is a self portrait.
A picture that Spirit took of itself
on day 330 of the mission.
And the solar arrays are brown.
They are coated with dust.
Dust in the Martian atmosphere
settles out of the atmosphere and it
just coats horizontal
surfaces on the rover.
When this rover was brand new,
straight off the showroom floor,
those solar arrays would put out about
900 watt hours of power per day.
So enough energy to run a 100 watt
light bulb for nine hours.
By the time this picture was taken,
with all the dust on the arrays,
that number was hovering between
250 and 300 watt hours.
And we think that death for the vehicle
was somewhere a little below 200.
So it was looking like
Spirit was close to the end.
And then one marvelous day, this happened.
A lucky gust of wind hit the vehicle,
cleaned it off, and overnight the power
went back up to 850 watt hours.
Pure dumb luck.
It was as if this had happened.
Somebody sent me this picture
I thought this was great.
What was really going on, check this out.
Look at this.
Dust devils.
Little Martian mini tornadoes that go
whirling through the
scene in the summertime.
I'll play this again.
I love this thing.
You almost see Dorothy and Todo
flying through all of that.
Check this out.
What was that, anybody know?
Eclipse, I heard it, yes eclipse.
Mars has two moons,
the names are Phobos and Deimos.
This is the moon Phobos
passing in front of the sun.
This is the first solar eclipse
ever witnessed from the
surface of another planet.
There's no science in this at all,
we just did it cause we could.
And that's a sunset.
On Mars the sky is pink in the daytime,
and it turns blue at sunset.
It's the opposite of Earth.
Now this sunset picture,
this beautiful image,
this was taken by Spirit.
Where things stand with
the Spirit rover right now
is we have not heard from
Spirit in about a year.
Spirit we managed to coax through three
very long dark difficult Martian winters.
By the time the fourth winter came
the mobility system, the wheels were
sufficiently crippled
that we could no longer
force Spirit up onto steep slopes
so it would point the solar
arrays towards the sun.
And it's beginning to appear that Spirit
may not have survived
the most recent winter.
We have dug very deeply
into our bag of tricks
to contact the vehicle we have
another few things to try,
we're gonna keep trying
for a little while longer,
but Spirit may have reached it's end.
Opportunity on the other hand,
is still doing well.
Let me talk about the
Opportunity mission now.
These slides show the
Opportunity landing site.
We chose the landing site for Opportunity
not because of it's topography,
no big hole in the
ground, no dry riverbed.
We chose it on the
basis of it's chemistry.
The picture at the right
shows data from an infrared spectrometer
collected from orbit.
The blue stuff is boring old lava again
but the red and yellow and green,
that's a mineral called hematite.
Hematite's an iron oxide,
it's a mineral that is present in rust.
And it's a mineral that sometimes,
not always but often forms as a result
of the action of liquid water.
So this hematite
signature is like a beacon
visible from space saying
hey come land here.
Water may have been here.
Now this picture here shows an image
of what the landing site
looks like close up.
Very smooth, very flat,
extremely safe for landing,
very easy for driving, great landing site.
But, the thing that made
me nervous about this site
is that it's so smooth
and so flat I feared
that we might not ever encounter
the topography that we
would need to expose
the bedrock we would want to see.
Turns out I need not have worried.
These are some of my favorite images
from the entire mission.
When our vehicle was landing,
as it's descending on that parachute,
it had mounted on the
underside of the lander
a camera that was looking
down at the surface.
That camera snapped off three pictures,
as we're going through this violent
and rapid landing process.
The little black dot that you see
just to the left of that crater,
that's the shadow of the parachute, okay.
This picture at the lower right is just
the same scene being viewed obliquely.
Now what the red curve is, the red curve
is the reconstruction of the trajectory
that our spacecraft followed as we went
through the landing process.
So here we are coming
screaming in from space
hundreds of kilometers an hour,
right here, we fire those rocket motors
and we cut the airbags free and they fall
to the surface and begin to bounce.
Now the wind that afternoon on Mars
was blowing from the south.
And so the trajectory bends to the north,
bounce bounce bounce bounce
bounce bounce bounce,
and then reading the green perfectly,
the trajectory bends to the left,
and goes right into a little
20 meter diameter impact crater.
Tiger Woods on his best day
could not have accomplished this, again,
it was just pure dumb luck.
We opened our eyes,
and there was this spectacular outcrop
of layered bedrock in
the wall of the crater
right in front of the rover.
Now the night that we landed,
when we first saw these images
we didn't know which crater we were in.
So we didn't know how far
away the crater wall was.
So we didn't know how big the outcrop was.
And on the night that
we landed when my team
saw this massive outcrop that we were
gonna have to negotiate,
the name that they gave it that night,
what they called it at
first was The Great Wall.
That was the name.
Then we took some stereo images
and did a little trigonometry,
little tiny outcrop great big rover
the great wall is about
this high. (audience laughs)
But its small size was part of it's charm
because what that meant was that this
layering that we were
seeing was very very fine.
You gotta remember this
is only three weeks
after we had landed at Gusev crater
with Spirit and seen nothing but lava.
Here we clearly had something
very different on our hands.
The first thing we went
looking for while we were
still on the lander was the hematite,
that was what brought us here.
Our infrared spectrometer is
good at detecting hematite,
we went looking for it,
again red is lots of
hematite, blue is none.
There's lots of hematite
outside the crater
and some in the soil on the crater wall.
There's a bit of hematite in the outcrop,
not nearly as much.
And then on the crater floor in blue,
there are these weird splotches that have
no hematite at all.
The splotches are the airbag bounce marks.
So you bounce in the dirt here
and hematite goes away.
This is one of the first of many clues.
I've show you this picture before,
you can see the airbag
bounce marks very smooth,
and in between, where the
hematite is there's this gravel.
So we're thinking ah, the
hematite must be in the gravel.
We drove off the lander,
we looked down with our cameras and
took the first good picture of that gravel
and here it is,
and we start to notice that those grains
of gravel looked awfully round.
So we took out our microscope
and we took this picture.
And I will remember as long as I live
where I was standing, and how I felt,
and the unrepeatable words that I said,
when I saw this picture.
The surface of Mars at this landing site
is littered with an uncountable number
of little round things.
And they're four, five, six
millimeters in diameter,
and they are absolutely everywhere.
We had no idea what we were dealing with.
We drove over to the outcrop,
and what we quickly learned was that
the little round things are embedded in
the outcrop like blueberries in a muffin.
The muffin is soft, the
blueberries are hard.
The muffin erodes away and
the blueberries fall out.
And they're everywhere.
Now at this point of
course we're desperate
to know what the blueberries
are actually made of.
We suspected that they
were made of hematite.
Now on the end of the arm,
we have a spectrometer that's
a wonderful hematite detector.
The problem with that spectrometer is that
it's field of view,
this is a picture taken
with our microscope.
It's three centimeters across.
Okay the field of view
of that spectrometer
is a centimeter and a half.
So if you try to go up to just one little
blueberry embedded in the rock
what you wind up with is a
spectrometer whose field of view
is filled by a little bit of blueberry
and a whole lotta muffin.
And it's hard to figure
out what you're looking at.
So what we needed instead was
a gathering of blueberries.
We found one, right here
there's a place where there's a little
bowl shaped depression in the rocks
and a bunch of the blueberries had rolled
down into it, we called it the Berry Bowl.
And we stuffed our spectrometer
into the Berry Bowl
and we made a measurement of this stuff
and sure enough, the berries
are made of hematite.
Now after looking at
these things for awhile
what we came to realize
is that the blueberries
are what geologists call concretions.
Concretions form in
sedimentary rocks on Earth
that are saturated with liquid water.
And there's some mineral
dissolved in the rocks,
or dissolved in the water
that wants to precipitate out.
It's supersaturated.
And it finds a little nucleation point
and it begins to precipitate.
And it adds layer upon layer upon layer
as more minerals precipitate and it grows,
building a little hard spherical nodule
in the rock sort of like the
way an oyster builds a pearl.
So what this is showing us
is that at this location
at one time in the past
the rocks here were
saturated with liquid water.
Now we were also interested
in whether or not
water came to the surface.
And this is some experiments done where
you have water flowing over sand.
If you've ever looked into the bed
of a sandy stream you've seen this.
Where water flows over
sand it makes ripples.
Then the ripples propagate downstream
and the key thing here that you observe
is that the crests of those
ripples are not straight.
They're highly sinuous over length scales
of five or ten centimeters.
And that sinuosity of the ripple crest
is the signature of water as the fluid
that is transporting the sediments.
Here's the same thing being
simulated in the computer.
So sinuous crests and ripples,
propagating downstream, and
look what's left behind.
What's left behind in
the sedimentary record
is not flat lying sediments,
instead what you get is
these little concave upward
smiley shapes in the rocks,
five or ten centimeters in size.
Here's the real thing, these are from
some sediments in the Colorado river,
in southwestern United States,
and here it is on Mars.
Little smiley shapes in the rocks,
these are rare, we haven't
seen these all over the place
we've seen them only in a few spots.
And what they say is
that not only was there
water beneath the ground,
but occasionally water
came up to the surface
and flowed across the ground here on Mars.
We spent 60 wonderful Martian days
exploring this little crater,
you see tire tracks everywhere.
And then we left,
and the place that we went
to was Endurance crater.
Endurance crater, 150 meters in diameter,
20 meters deep it's this spectacular thing
and I remember telling reporters,
telling people in the news media,
oh yeah when we get to Endurance crater
it's gonna be great
we're gonna be able to go
down into the crater and look at all
these layers in the rocks.
We got to the crater rim and it scared
the living daylights out of us.
I mean that looks like an
overhanging cliff, there,
that's exactly what it is.
This is the kind of place
where if we screwed up,
our little rover could
fall off a cliff and die.
It was a frightening place.
But look at those layered
sedimentary rocks.
We had to find some way to
get down into this crater.
Now I showed you that picture before
with the little outcrop and the big rover,
here it is to scale at Endurance.
This is a very frightening place.
But I will tell you,
that at 200 days of
operating in this crater
we drove that little rover
down into the crater,
and up to this spot right here.
We were parked right on
top of that rock there
and I'll show you a
picture take from there
in just a second.
Now when we first took on
this task we had no idea
what the rover could do in
terms of climbing steep slopes.
We had not designed it
for this kind of thing.
So we had to test it and
we went out, literally,
we went out to Home Depot,
and we bought a bunch of paving stones,
we got a bunch of sand,
I had grad students
gluing BBs onto the rocks,
to make blueberries.
And we took our test rover and we would
tilt this thing at different angles
and run it up and down
the slop and it turns out
the rover climbs pretty well,
it can handle slopes
up to about 34 degrees.
So into the crater we went.
Over a period of months,
we worked our way slowly systematically
down through this beautifully exposed
stack of layered rocks.
And each time we got into
a new layer we put in
a hole with the RAT,
we'd look at it with our microscope,
we'd look at it with our spectrometers,
we'd study how things changed as we went
down the section, as a
geologist would put it.
In geology what you try
to do in sedimentary rocks
is you try to construct what's called
a stratigraphic section,
measurements through a whole set of layers
and that's what we did here,
it's the first stratigraphic
section ever done on Mars.
We got down on the floor of the crater
we found some really weird stuff.
This is the rock that when
the picture first came down
my team called it the petrified
Martian dinosaur brain.
When this one came down
one of the guys on the team
said now that's what a rock
from another planet should look like.
No idea what's going on there.
We then worked our way up
to the base of that cliff,
and we took this image.
And I wish I could show you this image
in it's full high resolution glory
there's about three IMAX screens
worth of data in this image.
I'm gonna just zero in on one tiny little
section of it up here.
There it is.
And the entire image is that good.
And every single image
that we've ever taken
since the day we landed on Mars
is on the web, anybody can download it,
anybody can work with it,
this is a treasure trove of data that
people are gonna be working with
for decades into the future.
We left the crater,
and the next place that we
went was our heat shield.
Okay you remember the heat shield,
it protects the vehicle as you're
descending through the atmosphere,
when we don't need the heat shield anymore
we drop it off the vehicle,
it falls to the surface,
and it hits the surface.
Here's the heat shield at the top
as it looked last time I saw it
in Cape Canaveral in Florida,
here it is busted into
pieces on the Martian surface
along with the crater
that it made when it hit.
Now we went to visit the heat shield
not to learn about Mars,
we went to it to learn about heat shields.
For decades, engineers
have been given the task
of designing a heat shield that will work
in the very poorly understood
Martian atmosphere.
But until our mission not
one of those engineers
had had the luxury of
seeing their creation
after it had done it's job.
We were able to drive
up to this heat shield,
take our microscope and take a microscopic
image of a cross section
through the broken heat shield,
and give that image to the engineer who
had designed and built the thing,
so he could assess how
well it had performed.
Now at the same time that we're doing
our engineering investigation
on the heat shield,
you know we're scientists so we're
looking around for rocks.
And we saw one right
next to the heat shield,
here it is.
We named it Heat Shield Rock.
And we went over to Heat Shied Rock
and we measured it's composition,
turns out this thing is not made of
conventional rock at all.
This thing is made of a nickel-iron alloy.
It's a meteorite.
This is an iron meteorite
just sitting there
right next to the heat shield.
Again, pure dumb luck.
I told the team we shouldn't stay here
this is obviously a place where
big metal objects fall from the sky.
We drove away from the heat shield,
and we embarked on a long
arduous drive to the south.
Many kilometers.
And as we got farther
and farther to the south,
the nature of the terrain changed.
And where it once had been
perfectly smooth and flat,
now we began to see these
little wind blown ripples.
And the farther south we got,
the bigger and bigger and bigger they got.
And we blithely just
drove over those things.
Bombing along up one side, down the next,
we drove over hundreds of these things.
And then one terrible day,
we hit a ripple that was somehow,
and I still don't
completely understand this,
but we hit a ripple that was just a little
bit different from the
hundreds that had come before,
and instead of driving over our wheels
broke through the crust of this thing,
and started to sink in.
And we did 50 meters of wheel turns
thinking we were driving across the plains
when in fact we were just sinking
deeper and deeper and
deeper into this thing.
We came in the next
morning and all six wheels
were buried over the hubcaps.
This was a bad day.
Now the first rule in
a situation like this
is don't do anything stupid that's gonna
make the problem worse.
The sun is shining, we
have electrical power,
the vehicle's safe, it's
certainly not going anywhere,
we have time to figure out the problem.
Now when we built the rovers
we actually built four of them.
Spirit and Opportunity are on Mars
but we have two that
are back here on Earth.
And we can use the ones
that are here on Earth
to simulate predicaments that
we've gotten ourselves into
on Mars and then try to
figure a way out of it.
In order to figure a way
out of this predicament
what we needed was a large quantity
of fake Martian soil.
Now if you're ever called upon to make
fake Martian soil, here's the
recipe that you should use.
It is roughly equal parts play sand,
the stuff in kids sandboxes,
clay, and diatomaceous earth.
The stuff that's used in
swimming pool filters.
Once we figured out this recipe
a bunch of engineers in pick up trucks
fanned out across the
LA basin and bought up
literally tons of these three ingredients.
I mean people were getting algae in their
swimming pools across
Los Angeles all summer
because we bought all
the diatomaceous earth.
We brought it back to JPL,
and we mixed it together,
and we created mounds and pits and drifts
and dunes and we drove the rover into it
and we got it stuck.
And we spent two and a
half weeks rehearsing,
trying to find the optimal way to extract
the robot from a sand
dune on another planet.
There are a lot of things you can do.
You can steer the wheels back and forth,
to try to open up the holes
that they're in a little bit.
You can run the wheels
at different velocities
you can rock the vehicle.
We tried all those
things and a bunch more.
After two and a half weeks we
found the optimal technique,
the optimal technique it turns out was to
put it in reverse and
gun it. (audience laughs)
You know there's no place
you go to look this stuff up.
So here we are, gunning it on Mars,
this is the left front wheel.
Here's the left rear wheel I mean
we were really stuck, we were in trouble.
We had to do 192 meters
worth of wheel turns
to get the rover to move one meter.
But one marvelous Saturday morning,
after six weeks stuck in the feature
that we later came to call Purgatory Dune,
the vehicle popped out,
and we have been treating those ripples
with much greater respect ever since.
So this shows where we operated
over a period of years.
Here's Eagle crater, that's
a one kilometer scale bar.
Here's Eagle crater where we landed,
there's Endurance where
we spent all that time,
the heat shield was about here,
Purgatory Dune was about here.
The place we were hoping to get to
was Victoria crater.
Now you notice that the craters on here
are all named after famous
ships of exploration.
Eagle of course was the
lunar module on Apollo 11,
Endurance was Shackleton's ship.
Victoria was one of Magellan's ships.
Magellan left Spain with five ships,
Victoria was one of them,
260 men on board,
with the intention of
circumnavigating the globe.
Magellan himself was
killed in the Philippines.
After three years at sea
the one remaining ship
from the original five,
with 18 remaining surviving sailors
from the original 260,
limped back to Spain.
So we chose that name
for this crater because
we thought it was a suitable
analogy for the shape
that we would be in with
our beat up little rover
being driven by 18
surviving graduate students,
if we ever got as far as the crater.
But I'm pleased and proud
to say that we did make it.
This is a wonderful
image of Victoria crater.
This was taken from orbit,
by NASA's Mars Reconnaissance Orbiter.
This was a marvelous coincidence,
at almost the exact moment
that we rolled up to the
rim of Victoria crater,
MRO went into orbit around Mars,
turned on its camera for the first time
and one of the very first pictures it took
was this image of Victoria.
I'll blow up just that
little portion of it,
there it is,
if you look carefully, that's Opportunity.
In fact if you look really carefully,
You can see the shadow of the camera mast
being cast on the Martian surface.
It was really nice to see our rover again.
We spent two years
exploring Victoria crater.
And you can see in this image,
taken after about a years worth,
the wheel tracks that we made
as we worked our way along
the rim of this crater.
The rover drivers told me
that when this was done
that was gonna spell out hi Steven,
I'm not seeing it. (audience laughs)
Seriously, these wheel
tracks to me actually
represent one of the
finest accomplishments
in the history of space robotic systems.
And you gotta realize
the rovers are operated
by a group of engineers
whose first and foremost
job is to keep the vehicle safe.
We're driving it along the top of an eight
meter tall cliff, with a
bunch of scientists saying,
go closer, go closer, go
closer. (audience laughs)
And time and again they
took us right to the edge.
And we got just spectacular
images in the process.
Here's one of them,
this is a place called Cape St. Mary
that cliff's about eight meters tall,
I'm gonna zoom in on this portion of it,
there it is.
Look at the layering.
This is what geologists call cross bedding
just spectacular layering exposed
in the wall of this cliff.
What this is telling us
is this was an ancient
sand dune, billions of years ago on Mars,
with this sand blowing
around in the Martian wind.
I don't know if you've been to
a lot of talks by geologists,
but geologists when they show a picture
of an outcrop they always
put their rock hammer
in it for scale.
So there's my virtual
rock hammer for scale,
I wish it were my real one.
But anyway, just spectacular stuff.
A couple years ago we
left Victoria crater,
and we have continued
our trek to the south.
So let's see.
Endurance crater is that little tiny dot
right below the letter
U in the word endurance.
Big old Victoria crater,
800 meters in diameter,
is right there.
As we speak today, the rover
Opportunity is right there.
We have driven 28 and a half kilometers,
and we are now just four
and a half kilometers away
from the rim of Endeavor crater.
Endeavor crater is 25
kilometers in diameter,
it is hundreds of meters deep,
it's rim is composed of
materials that we know
by looking at it from orbit
are fundamentally different
from anything we've ever seen
before, with either rover.
If we can manage to keep this very old
and very tired rover going for another
four and a half kilometers,
and get to the rim of Endeavor,
it's gonna be like the mission
has started all over again.
Are we gonna make it,
I don't have any idea,
but we're sure gonna try.
This picture came down this morning.
This was taken yesterday on Mars,
we are back into very
smooth very flat terrain,
the rover is making very good progress.
These wheel tracks are
from a single days drive
of 120 meters, so we're
making really good progress,
and if the vehicle stays healthy,
I'm looking forward to getting to the rim
of Endeavor crater before too long.
Whenever I give talks about
the Mars Exploration Rover project,
I always end them with this slide.
I wrote a book about the
project called Roving Mars
and in an appendix of that
book I made an attempt
to list the names of all
the people who worked
on the project.
There are more than
4000 names on that list
I'm just one member of
that 4000 person team.
Here are some more people on the team,
this is at Cape Canaveral,
down in Florida,
this is the night that
we sent the Opportunity
spacecraft which you see at upper right,
out to the launch pad.
For every one of us who has had
the remarkable experience
of being part of this mission,
it has been in the literally
sense of the phrase,
the adventure of a lifetime.
And I want to thank you very much
for inviting me here to tell
you about it. Thanks a lot.
(audience claps)
Thank you.
Yes.
Can we bring the lights up?
Let's bring the lights up and I'd be happy
to take your questions.
Questions, oh you got a
microphone, there we go, alright.
- [Audience Member] I do recall that they,
they kicked up some, it
looked like a white stuff
on the tracks, it looked
like a salt or ice,
was it actually liquid water ice?
- No, we have not found ice at all
with either one of the rovers,
we, as you saw with Spirit,
we did have that very bright stuff,
that turned out to be silica.
There have been other places where
what we have found turned
out to be sulfate salts,
but nowhere have we found ice.
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
- We're pretty close
to the equator on Mars
and so you wouldn't really
expect it, it's too warm there.
The Phoenix lander, which landed
78 degrees north latitude,
was able to dig into the
soil with it's robotic arm,
and five centimeters below the surface,
found bright deposits of ice.
So that's been done, but
that's closer to the pole.
- [Audience Member] That was ice.
- That was ice, yes, that was
a different mission. Yeah.
- [Audience Member 2] 120 meters per day
is very impressive for a machine
on Mars but for us here on Earth
we could walk that in a few minutes,
so I'm curious how does
the rover spend it's time
does it spend a lot of time thinking where
it's going next?
- Yeah, that's part of it, it depends on
where you are in the drive.
So why can you only do
about 120 meters a day.
Fundamentally we're limited by power.
Right now the solar arrays on Opportunity
are pretty dusty,
right now Opportunity's got
about 400 watt hours per cell.
It's 400 watt hours to do everything,
all of the driving, all the computing,
taking the images,
transmitting the data to Earth,
running the heaters to keep the vehicle
warm at night, et cetera.
So we're fundamentally power limited.
The way we drive the vehicle
is the first part of the drive,
we will just simply command
it, we call it blind driving,
and what it means is we
know the terrain is safe
we just say rover, go,
and it will just drive
at top speed you apply
full voltage to the wheels,
you get about six centimeters a second.
And that's how fast it goes.
Once we've gone about 80 meters out,
then we've driven so far
that the images are not
good enough to recognize
potential obstacles
and that's when we turn on that automatic
hazard avoiding stuff.
When the rover's doing that it is
excruciatingly slow.
You can watch one of these rovers,
we've tested them on Earth and it will
go like this, and it'll
stop and take a picture,
and it'll think for
two and a half minutes,
about what to do before it will move on.
The computer inside this rover
was a smoking hot machine in about 1987.
It runs at a screaming 10mips.
And so the rover's, I mean
your cellphone is a lot smarter
than my rovers.
My rovers are on Mars though.
And so it's excruciatingly slow
but yeah we're fundamentally limited
by how much power we have.
If the solar rays were completely clean
we'd be able to get more mileage per day.
- [Audience Member 2] Thank you.
- Yeah, sure.
- [Audience Member 3]
I was very interested
to see the microscopic images.
I had wondered from the beginning of
the Mars Exploration Program,
why microscopes were not
put on the earliest rovers.
- Yeah, the microscopes,
it has been one of the most
fundamentally useful things
on our payload.
I think the answer to your question is,
I mean recognize there
weren't too many missions
that preceded ours.
There were the two Viking landers,
Viking was fundamentally about looking for
microbial life in the soil,
and rather than a
microscopic approach to that
which is very difficult with even soil
samples on Earth, I mean you'd need an
electron microscope to do it properly,
which is very hard to do for space,
the approach they took
was a set of experiments
that you would look at a labeled release
experiment where you'd feed it a nutrient
and look at the gases come off.
The next mission was Mars Pathfinder,
and that was fundamentally
an engineering mission
that wasn't really about science at all
and the next mission after that was us,
so, it kind of makes sense.
- [Audience Member 3] The
second part of what I'm asking
really is going forward,
I mean clearly what we'd
really like to see is evidence of life, so
what we need is not only
the very fine microscopy,
but also to be able to dig
down to where there's water.
And I realize that's a big challenge
but I was interested in your remarks.
- That's a very big challenge but it's
a very important one.
Right now, the next missions going to Mars
is the Mars Science
Laboratory, a big rover,
what it focuses on
primarily is trying to look
not for water but to look for,
at very very low concentrations
organic materials
in the rocks and the soil.
And then the next step
after that is probably
to bring samples back
from Mars and that process
I hope and expect will involve a drill
that can go a meter or
two below the surface.
- [Audience Member 3] Thank you.
- [Announcer] Please join me in thanking
professor Squyres for the
wonderful presentation.
(audience clapping)
(bright instrumental music)